estoy en el ejercicio de khan academy
que se llama encuentra uno en la recta
numérica y nos piden que hagamos
exactamente eso nos dicen mueve el punto
al 1 en la recta numérica y tenemos un
punto interactivo que se puede mover
sobre la recta así que vamos a pensar en
cómo podemos encontrar a uno
como siempre te invito a que pausa es el
vídeo y que al menos pienses en cómo
intentaré hacerlo o pon tu dedo en la
pantalla donde creas que está uno y
después vamos a trabajar juntos
ok nos dicen dónde está el cero y nos
dicen dónde estás siete cuartos entonces
una forma de hacerlo es pensar cuántos
de estos espacios iguales hay entre cero
y siete cuartos así que veamos son 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 así que hay 7 espacios iguales
para llegar a siete cuartos significa
que cada uno de estos espacios es un
cuarto porque entonces sería un cuarto
dos cuartos tres cuartos cuatro cuartos
cinco cuartos seis cuartos y siete
cuartos muy bien estamos haciendo un
buen progreso entonces donde se
encuentra uno bueno uno es cuatro
cuartos así que iremos a cuatro cuartos
con cuarto dos cuartos tres cuartos
cuatro cuartos aquí es donde está uno lo
importante que debemos tener en cuenta
es que la única forma para saber que
cada uno de estos espacios que hay entre
una marca y otra es un cuarto es decir
mira siete de estos espacios iguales nos
lleva a siete cuartos así que cada uno
de ellos debe de ser un cuarto y por lo
tanto cuatro de ellos cuatro cuartos es
igual a uno hagamos otro ejemplo de
nuevo nos dicen nueve el punto al uno en
la recta numérica punto de do en donde
creas que estará uno bien pausa el vídeo
y hazlo
muy bien de alguna forma esto es un poco
más sencillo porque nos dicen que el
espacio entre 0 y la siguiente marca es
un sexto donde está uno bueno uno o un
entero es seis sextos así que veamos
tengo un sexto dos sextos tres sextos
cuatro sextos cinco sextos y después
seis sextos ya está aquí es donde está
uno en la recta numérica